[Music]
on Christmas morning 2021 a mighty
rocket burst into
life quickly climbing away from the
ground it soared into the cloud Laden
sky and headed for the darkness of deep
space its Target was 1.5 million kilom
from Earth at a place where the
gravities of the Sun and our planet
combine in a very particular way in this
spot known as a lrange point the payload
would be held in space fixed in relation
to the Earth as it circles the sun once
in location this payload began its
delicate deployment immense sheets
unfurled to shade it from the glare of
the Sun as hexagonal mirror segments
unfolded and clicked into place it then
waited until it cooled to The Frigid
background of
space after several months the device
was ready for Operation the latest in a
long line of technological leaps a
signal was sent from the earth for this
most recent Observer to awaken to open
its eyes and appearer into the
darkness after 30 years and 10
billion the James web Space Telescope
had finally
arrived James Webb possesses a 6 and 1/2
M mirror and cameras tuned to see in the
infrared its mission is to map the lives
of young stars in our own Milky Way and
hunt for life on planets in orbit around
other Suns but it was its view of the
early universe that caused the first
controversy the power of James web
sitting far from the glow of the earth
is its ability to peer far back in time
its sensitive instruments can discern
light that has traveled for more than 10
billion years emitted by the first star
in the first fledgling galaxies through
web's eyes we can witness the birth of
the
universe astronomers of course had
expectations of just what web should see
in the infant Cosmos over the 20th
century they had come to realize that
galaxies even our own Milky Way had
grown over time they start as small
groups of stars but through collisions
and mergers small galaxies grow larger
until over many billions of years
galaxies with hundreds of billions of
stars appear in the cosmos but as
astronomers poured over the new images
from James web something did not seem
right as they peered into the epoch of
the earliest Stars they expected nothing
but small featuress blobs but instead
they saw something
unexpected large well-formed galaxies
peeking out of the darkness objects that
made no sense
for since the turn of the 21st century
astronomers have believed themselves to
be in an era of precision
cosmology they had determined that
gravity in the universe was dominated by
a strange dark matter and the expansion
of the universe accelerated due to an
even stranger Dark Energy both of these
have fed into the most accurate model of
the universe we have a model known as
Lambda C
M and yet James web had revealed large
galaxies appearing to exist in the first
billion years of the life of the cosmos
going against the predictions of this
hardfought model some scientists have
been driven back to the drawing board to
revise their theories of Galaxy
formation but others much more worried
fear for the very foundations of our
understanding of the
universe but this is not the first time
that new eyes on the sky have demanded a
revision of the Cosmos since the
earliest of times people have looked to
the Stars to uncover the workings of the
universe and since the earliest of times
they have been surprised by what they
saw and so what do we understand about
those first galaxies forming in the
black just after the big bang and do
these surprises thrown up by James web
derail our understanding of the universe
or help strengthen its foundations even
further
[Music]
the first food eaten in space was a beef
and liver paste that Yuri Karin squeezed
into his mouth like salty toothpaste he
followed it up with chocolate sauce this
video has been sponsored by Factor the
best healthiest meal delivery service
out there and an Impossible Dream for
early
astronauts their healthy menus are
updated weekly and include include more
than 27 meals and 33 add-on options you
can choose your favorite meals or let
Factor craft your order based on your
taste preferences and meal history they
offer keto calorie smart Chef's Choice
and vegan and veggie options which is
fantastic for me as I've been trying to
cut down on my meat consumption Factor
takes the guesswork out of food shopping
and meal prep saving you time and energy
for other things the no hassle prepared
foods make sure you always have
something nutritious on hand when you
don't have time to think about making a
meal
so head to factor75.com or click the
link below and use the code
H50 to get 50% off your first Factor box
thanks to factor for supporting
educational content on
[Music]
YouTube The Story Goes that Galileo
galile was the first to successfully
turn a telescope to the skies the device
a simple arrangement of lenses had only
recently been invented its Earthly
employment having mainly been navigation
surveying and of course Warfare but
Galileo's Focus was the Motions of the
heavens the invention of the telescope
is implicitly tied to the birth of
modern science a little more than half a
century after Galileo Isaac Newton also
turning his attention Skyward replacing
lenses with a silvered mirror he
revolutionized the design of telescopes
sharpening the image and constructing
the Foreigner of day's massive
telescopes including James web but
unlike Galileo Newton's observations
didn't revolutionize the cosmos but his
discoveries of the laws of motion and
gravity certainly did now the orbits of
planets moons and comets were understood
not to be a sign of the Divine but the
results of physical laws that pervade
the entire
universe astronomical telescopes
steadily developed after the time of
Newton and through each Advance more
more and more light could be collected
the Improvement of optical systems
resulting in clearer and sharper images
astronomers now had the tools to reveal
the true beauty and complexity of the
universe and so just what did they
[Music]
see as well as stars and planets the
skies were often home to magnificent
comets and by the mid 1700s French
astronomer Charles Messier was hunting
for these Heavenly Bodies he was looking
for the fuzzy coma of a comet formed as
ice and dust a boiled off the cometry
surface but in his search he found
himself constantly
frustrated we now know that comets are
rocky icy bodies that orbit the Sun and
Messier had expected the fuzzy coma to
move night after night during the
comet's travels but he came across
numerous fuzzy objects that stubbornly
remained in place not changing at all
Messier decided to elay his frustration
by cataloging all these anomalies
ignoring them if he happened to spot one
and so though messier's catalog of 110
objects mainly contains simple clouds of
gas within our Milky Way unknown to
Messier many of his objects were much
much more
distant throughout the 19th century with
better telescopes astronomers had found
structure in some of messier's objects
swirling spiral patterns hinting the
objects must be rotating eventually two
giants of astronomy went head-to-head to
settle the question and by 1921 a great
debate on the nature of these spiral
nebula
began the protagonists were harow
shapley and hea Curtis in shapley's mind
our own Milky Way was the entire
universe whilst Curtis argued that they
were extremely distant individual ual
galaxies lingering out there though the
debate ended in stalemate very soon the
question would be settled once and for
all by the 20th century telescope
mirrors had grown to more than a meter
in size and in the 192s Edwin Hubble
used the 2.5 M hooker telescope to
survey the
heavens it was then that the scale of
the cosmos grew immensely and
definitively as he proved that spiral
nebuli thy far beyond our Milky Way
whilst the flow of galaxies away from us
show we live in an expanding
Universe in a few short years our view
of the cosmos had been completely
revolutionized and Rewritten countless
galaxies each with billions of stars
were scattered Across the Universe in a
cosmos no longer seen to be unchanging
and eternal but a dynamical place
expanding and and evolving springing
into existence at some time in the
[Music]
past the story of this big bang our
Cosmic Birth has been told many many
times and after the universe's fiery
creation we understood it was smooth and
featuress but this still left a
question where did all the galaxies we
see today come from just what forces
sculpted the
universe throughout the 20th century
telescopes continued to grow and scour
the cosmos more Mysteries were revealed
dark matter and dark energy amongst the
biggest and by the dawn of the 21st
Century 10 meter telescopes now stared
into the darkness these Earthbound
telescopes were complemented by
telescopes in space space the most
famous of these being the Hubble Space
Telescope put in orbit in
1990 its mirror only 2.5 m in diameter
is small compared to the behemoths on
Earth but sitting beyond the shimmering
effects of the atmosphere it can see
more clearly than the others over the
last three decades the sharpness of
Hubble's observations has wowed both
astronomers and the public and posters
of spectacular images are stuck to walls
all around the globe but not long after
Hubble was placed in space and opened
its eyes on the universe plans for its
replacement a bigger more powerful
telescope were put in
motion the mission had to be ambitious
pushing the limits of technology and
striding past the view of Hubble the
planned mirror was to be so large it
wouldn't fit into even the largest
rocket so would have to be segmented and
folded like scientific origami and one
of the most powerful Rockets would be
needed to to fling it into the darkness
of
space through numerous delays and cost
blowouts this new telescope the James
web Space Telescope found itself on the
Launchpad and on that Christmas morning
2021 it blasted away from the earth
astronomers have pinned their hopes on
this1 billion feat of technology and
science hoping to conclusively answer
the biggest question of all just one
where did galaxies come
from how can you use a map of the
universe to chart a course through the
center of an
atom the James web Space Telescope is
the latest in a long line of telescopes
we've since Skyward but it is not the
strangest that prize could well go to
the plank satellite launched in 2009 and
for its 3 years of operation the coldest
known object in outer space at 0. 1°
above absolute zero its mission was not
to look at stars or galaxies but to map
the entire sky and counterintuitively
scientists have been able to scale down
this multi-billion lier wide map to plot
the microscopic World revealing the
landscape of the beginning of
time plank was the latest and a long
line of satellites used to map out the
cosmic microwave background the leftover
radiation from the first moments of the
universe this had been discovered in the
1960s and Plank's goal was to hunt for
ripples in this all Sky emission tiny
variations in the temperature of the
cosmic microwave background Across the
Universe the temperature of the cosmic
microwave background is about 2.75 de
above of absolute zero but soon after
its Discovery there were hints that this
temperature was not the same everywhere
at about one part in 10,000 in
temperature difference this pattern of
ripples was formed in the earliest
moments of the universe imprinted when
the cosmos was extremely different to
that we see around us today and yet
despite this vast Chasm of time these
ripples are essential for our very
existence as they reveal the ultimate
origin
of galaxies
themselves to seek out this origin of
galaxies we have to go back a very long
way back to about 10 Theus 36 seconds
after the universe came into being when
it was nothing but a roing sea of energy
and
particles at this time astronomers think
that the Universe drastically changed
the trigger is uncertain but for the
brief briest of periods the expansion of
the universe exploded cosmologists call
this violence inflation an event that
flattened the very SpaceTime geometry of
the
cosmos but by 10 Theus 32 seconds it was
all over and more sedate expansion
resumed the expansion of inflation froze
and emptied out the universe but as it
came to a close the immense energy of
inflation flooded back into the vacuum
and out of this emerged matter and
radiation electrons photons and quarks
smoothly filling space with the stuff of
today's
universe but not totally smoothly for
there were tiny almost imperceptible
ripples in the cosmos ripples that would
end up being crucial for our own
existence for Gravity reached out from
these over densities and began to draw
in other matter and it was these tiny
over densities that would become the
gravitational seeds of the galaxies we
see
today but where did these ripples come
from how far back does this origin story
go to understand the ultimate origin of
galaxies we have to pull the veil back
on the very earliest moments of the
cosmos the time before inflation
in these opening moments of time quantum
mechanics reign supreme at the smallest
scale much smaller than the scale of an
atom Quantum energy churns and roils
fluctuating in and out of existence
itself these fluctuations are
unpredictable governed by the
probabilistic world of the quantum and
defined by Heisenberg's uncertainty
principle this principle says that
energy can spontaneously appear from
nowhere as long as it rebalances and
pays back its energy debt in the
appropriate time scale but the onset of
inflation broke the harmony of this
Quantum loan system the rapid expansion
cuts off the repayment and the quantum
ripples in energy are frozen into space
it also inflates the size of the ripples
from microscopic to macroscopic and at
the end of inflation it's these ripples
that are filled with the matter of the
cosmos and this is how we can use a map
of the entire universe the cosmic
microwave background to investigate the
microscopic Quantum
[Music]
World despite these vast changes by the
close of inflation the universe was
still very young and as it cooled and
expanded it continued to evolve at a
millionth of a second protons and
neutrons solidified out of the particle
soup and at the 1 second Mark these
began to combine into the first
Elements by a couple of thousand seconds
these first steps of the universe were
complete the universe had expanded and
cooled and the nuclear furnace was
extinguished slowly these fires of
creation faded and died and the universe
was plunged into an Inky
Blackness these dark ages would envelop
the universe for a 100 million years but
just like the dark ages of early
medieval Europe they were far from
uneventful gravity's grip had grown
tighter as matter flowed from the less
dense areas into the denser
regions but just what was it flowing in
the
darkness of course there was the
subatomic soup of hydrogen and helium
nuclei along with electrons photons and
ethereal
neutrinos but hidden in the black there
was more much much more for as well as
atoms the Big Bang had created huge
quantities of other matter matter that
still dominates the mass of the cosmos
today in the darkness dark matter had
started to
flow as now this strange Dark Matter
dominated the gravitational PSE of the
universe and in the early Universe in
the darkness it was dark matter pooling
into the overdense regions the
gravitational pull of Dark Matter was
irresistible drawing in nuclear ey
electrons photons and
neutrinos in the darkness dense regions
grew and the first Whispers of galaxies
had truly
[Music]
begun but matter followed a different
path unlike Dark Matter whose physics is
extremely simple gas is extremely
complicated gas can Collide and shock
heat and importantly cool and so when
the universe was about 100 million years
old the gas was dense enough and cool
enough to finally
fragment these fragments collapsed under
the continuing action of gravity and as
they collapsed the density of the
fragments grew as they became more
spherical the temperatures of the cores
of these fragments soared and nuclear
reactions ignited finally the first
stars in the cosmos were born and light
began to trickle back into the universe
however these first stars were quite
different to their modern day
counterparts they were purely hydrogen
and helium and enormous many were more
than a 100 times more massive than our
sun they would burn bright for a few
million years before dying in supern
noi despite these brief lives their
intense light mainly ultraviolet and
x-rays changed the universe once again
this radiation spewed into the cosmos
lighting up the Heavens but as well as
this as their high energy photons
smashed into the immense clouds of
surrounding hydrogen they tore their
electrons clean off reionized the
universe more and more of the cosmos was
transformed back into plasma a situation
that remains today
99.9% of all Atomic matter across our
universe is in the form of superheated
plasma
as these first generations of stars
burnt through their deaths they polluted
the universe in their nuclear Hearts
heavier elements such as carbon and
oxygen had been forged and through their
explosive demise these elements had been
thrown into the black the chemical
enrichment of the universe was truly
underway and yet throughout all these
changes gravity never changed never
faltered it continued to draw matter
together and in homogeneities continued
to grow eventually groups of stars fell
together merging and forming larger
groups of stars the epoch of the first
galaxies had
arrived it's impossible to pinpoint
exactly when a galaxy is born Mass over
densities seeded by Quantum fluctuations
are continuous and whilst punctuated by
the first Stars bursting into life the
process of Galactic growth continues
inexorably but grow they do firstly
through a steady accretion and then
through collisions of more appreciable
chunks of matter cosmologists call these
chunks Halos Dark Matter gas and stars
Bound by their Mutual
gravity and as time goes on scattered
throughout the Universe more massive
gravitationally dominant Halos
emerge these dominant Halos become the
sight of future galactic growth and as
their gravitational influence grows so
did their dominance more and more matter
is drawn into their grasp providing the
raw material for building future
generations of
stars these initial stages of Galactic
growth were quite uneven the majority of
these baby galaxies small and growing
slowly more massive and intense Galactic
growth much rarer indeed this immense
spread of Galaxy masses is still
imprinted on the universe
today and for the smallest of galaxies
these initial stages of Life were quite
dangerous they could potentially host a
massive star Burning Brightly for a few
million years only for it to Supernova
with the violence of its death expelling
all other gas in the Galaxy the small
Galaxy's weak gravitational pole losing
this gas into the universe its star
forming life ended before it had barely
begun many many of these small but
extinguished galaxies would have
inhabited the early Universe Halos of
Dark Matter devoid of all atoms and of
All Stars these dead elusive ghost
galaxies were doomed to remain dark and
unseen and they should still fill our
universe
[Music]
today but more massive galaxies were
different in a larger Galaxy gravity
could draw the gas back in being
recycled into the next generation of
stars and so whilst many galaxies were
snuffed out in the early Cosmos others
grew fat on the stars and gas they
continued to consume in their deep
gravitational Wells new stars were born
lived and
died but these were different to those
of the first generation of stars through
each generation of stars heavier and
heavier elements are expelled and
pollute the cosmos and these are
recycled into subsequent
Generations these elements represent
barely a trace compared to the dominant
hydrogen and helium but their presence
drastically influences the life cycles
of their
hosts the heavier elements mixed into
the layers of the Stars change their
opacity this is a measure of how easy it
is for the nuclear energy at the stellar
heart to escape and in trapping
radiation Stars more similar to our sun
begin to be born with longer lifespans
and less explosive
ends as billions of years passed some
galaxies began to settle into a more
sedate
lifestyle but violence still existed in
the universe a violence that began at
the very start a violence that would go
on to create some of the most extreme
environments in the
cosmos to understand these and how the
first galaxies became the galactic zoo
we see today we will have to first take
a trip back to the middle of the 20th
century to a Time when astronomers were
facing a mystery on a truly Cosmic
[Music]
scale Carl jansky was confused it was
1932 the early days of transatlantic
radio communication the world was
getting used to beaming voices over
thousands of kilometers but there was
something about the signal he heard on
these Transmissions that troubled jansy
a persistent background hiss though it
wasn't the existence of this background
static that befuddled him but its
Immaculate timing fansy had found his
static varied with the time of day
differing in intensity on a regular
schedule how was this possible how could
his electronics know what time of day he
was taking his measurements even
stranger as his observations spun out
over day days weeks and into months he
noticed that the static was not quite
aligned with the 24 hours of the solar
day the timing of the varying noise
changed slowly but steadily drifting
across the sky appearing to be in sync
with the siderial day the time taken for
distant stars to circle the Earth the
difference was small just four minutes
but the implications were profound for
it meant the source of jansky's radio
noise lay well beyond the Earth and the
Sun
and resided deep in the
[Music]
heavens at the time many astronomers
were scouring the skies with their
telescopes focusing on the optical light
they knew arose from stars and galaxies
but jansy realized that another
electromagnetic radiation was arriving
from the universe and the era of radio
astronomy was
born unfortunately jansky would play no
further role in establishing the
groundwork having identified the source
of the radio noise his employer Bell
Labs set him other jobs to do but his
name is remembered used now as a unit of
intensity of radio waves from the sky
with the announcement of radio waves
from space others took up the mantle
soon radio waves from the Sun were
detected in the UK and the US and in the
US Gro Reber built the first true radio
telescope was the only radio astronomer
for a decade and made it clear that our
own Milky Way glowed in this new
light but that was not all for later
maps of the radio Sky showed there were
many many more sources there were
powerful radio emissions radiating from
small points all over the
sky and so the first quasi Stellar radio
sources or quazar began to be
found astronomers now know of more than
a million qu quazar spread throughout
the cosmos they've been discovered to be
powered by super massive black holes
with masses more than a billion times
that of our sun and are so powerful we
can see them from vast distances away
and back in time over more than 10
billion
years these super massive black holes
are thought to have perhaps formed from
the deaths of super massive first stars
and after feeding voraciously and
merging became the central gravitational
point of many larger
galaxies and so for the first few
billion years of the universe it burned
with activity the fires of the first
Stars the first galaxies and the first
quazars Shone brightly but after this
first age passed the Vigor of Youth
began to wne and Cosmic activity began
to calm the universe settled into a more
sedentary
life however over the last 10 billion
years though the rate of star formation
has steadily declined Galaxies have
continued to evolve and change driven by
the endless pull of gravity small
Galaxies have steadily grown into large
galaxies as they have accreted more
stars and dark matter and large Galaxies
have grown even larger feasting on their
Cosmic neighbors some Galaxies have been
completely shaped by their spin as
Cooling Galactic scale gas has collapsed
into a flattened pancake which
fragmented into Stars this immense dis
of stars rotating steadily has become
the defining feature of these galaxies
the beautiful spirals we spy through our
telescopes today but for other galaxies
their journey to spiral Beauty has been
cut short as collisions between more
massive Galaxies have violently torn
them apart and Rob them of their spin
instead of settling into rotating discs
they are transformed form Med into more
formless objects elliptical galaxies the
other major galaxy type spied in the
heavens and these elliptical galaxies
are a foreshadowing of our own Galactic
Destiny elliptical and spiral do not
capture all the designs of galaxies we
can see and astronomers have a further
classification the Irregulars to capture
the rest these misshapen Galaxy appear
to be suffering the scars of more recent
Galaxy interactions and so they are
caught maybe mid transformation before
they finally settle astronomers estimate
there may be a trillion galaxies lying
in the observable universe coming in a
wealth of sizes from Tiny to
immense most galaxies are small with
only a handful of billions of stars
within whil the largest we know of is
more than 200 times more massive than
our own Milky
Way one of the the most startling
discoveries of the last century was not
only the galaxies themselves but also
the realization that galaxies are not
simply scattered randomly throughout the
cosmos through the action of gravity the
quantum seeds that are imprinted at
inflation are shaped into a complex
network of mass known as The Cosmic web
volumes of underdensity are emptied out
with matter drawn towards more massive
regions while some galaxies and dark
matter remain these sparse regions can
extend for millions of light years the
outflowing matter gathers into immense
sheets and filaments and continues to be
drawn towards the most massive objects
in the
cosmos but just where are all these
galaxies heading on their Journeys out
of voids and through the sheets and
filaments in this complex Network in
which dark matter is distributed like a
sponge there are superdense region
regions it is these massive regions that
are the ultimate gravitational goal of
all
mass these are the clusters of
galaxies Galaxy clusters are incredible
places some home to many thousands of
galaxies these galaxies Sosh about in
immense Halos of dark matter that vastly
outweigh All of the Stars the greatest
concentration of mass in all of the
universe and that their hearts sit truly
immense monsters for it is here that the
most massive galaxies seen in the entire
Cosmos
grow these cluster Center galaxies
disappointingly named CD galaxies a true
Giants of the universe built from
hundreds of trillions of stars enveloped
in a massive quantity of Dark Matter
Cosmic behemoths they sit deep within
the well of gravity and are circled by
thousands of other other galaxies
zooming out even further astronomers
have found that clusters themselves
cluster together group together into
even more immense structures they call
superclusters in our patch of the
universe we appear to be embedded in the
Lan AA home to many millions of galaxies
although the question of whether gravity
holds superclusters together remains Up
For Debate just as galaxies come in an
immense range of sizes so do the
clusters of galaxies and even for each
of the smaller clusters there exists a
myriad of Galaxy structures these are
the groups most galaxies in the universe
live in such groups they are typically
home to one two or a handful of larger
galaxies similar in scale to our own
Milky Way with them will be a host of
smaller galaxies possibly hundreds of
dwarfs all bound together by their
Mutual gravity and that of the dark
matter that accompanies them in fact our
Milky Way lives inside such a group a
group we share with the Andromeda galaxy
and this local group as it is known
contains a wealth of other
[Music]
galaxies some of these are visible to
the naked eye namely the melanic clouds
seen in the southern hemisphere but more
than a hundred other galaxies are held
in the gravitational grip of this local
group most of these smaller Galaxies
have only come to light in the last few
decades revealed in deep surveys with
new telescopes that appear even deeper
into the darkness and the presence of
all these dwarfs orbiting amongst the
larger galaxies told the astronomers
something important that the epoch of
Galaxy evolution is far from
over Rodrigo iarta was a young graduate
student working towards his PhD at the
University of Cambridge he was studying
at The world-renowned Institute of
astronomy founded by the famous
cosmologist Fred Hil and his research
was focused on understanding the
Dynamics of stars near the Galactic
core but to do this he needed the power
of a telescope more than 15,000 km
away just outside the small country town
of kuna baraban sits the siding Springs
Observatory home to a number of
telescopes in the early 1970s it saw the
opening of the Anglo Australian
telescope with a 3.9 M mirror it was
state-of-the-art for its time and it
still leads the world today with unique
instrumentation Rodrigo had traveled to
Australia to measure the speeds and
chemistries of stars in the central
Galactic bulge using the power of an
instrument called Auto FIB mounted on
the Anglo Australian telescope with a
combination of optical fibers aluto FIB
could look at more than 50 stars at a
time and so in a few nights Rodrigo
could survey various observational
Fields across the Bulge astronomers
rarely make discoveries when sitting at
the telescope the raw data they take
usually requires processing and Analysis
to reveal its secrets with the Proto
internet of the early 1990s this meant
carrying your data home on tapes and
Rodrigo set to work under the often
cloudy and rainy Skies of the flat F of
Cambridge astronomers had made
predictions for the speeds of stars in
the central regions of the Galaxy
expecting stars to be zipping around on
random orbits unlike the circular paths
in the galactic disc and in some of his
targeted Fields this is just what
Rodrigo saw but in some Fields however
Rodrigo was presented with a
puzzle stars in the galactic bulge were
still there zipping back and forth but
there was something else stars all
moving together Stars whose origin could
not be in the center center of our Milky
Way like most astronomers Rodrigo's
first conclusion was that he had made a
mistake somewhere in his analysis
perhaps he had measured the speeds
incorrectly or missed something in the
predicted motions but eventually when he
had ruled out all other possibilities he
had to conclude what he saw was
real just what had he
uncovered together with his supervisors
Jerry Gilmore and Mike Irwin he came to
a radical conclusion the Stars he was
seeing were simply not part of the
Galaxy these stars were Intruders into
the Milky Way falling in from somewhere
outside what Rodrigo had found was the
Sagittarius dwarf a small Galaxy
crashing through our
own the Sagittarius dwarf was hidden in
plain sight with its feeble light spread
over a huge area of sky and when Rodrigo
poured over old photographic IM Imes of
the galactic center its image steadily
emerged it was clear from its appearance
that it was being tily disrupted by our
own Galaxy's gravity and in a few
billion years Sagittarius would be
completely destroyed its Stars added to
our
own since the 1990s it was realized that
Sagittarius was not a unique event and
that the Milky Way is consuming a number
of other dwarf galaxies and is
constantly growing Andromeda is also
wrapped in the tidal debris of recently
consumed dwarf galaxies the feeding that
began many billions of years ago
continuing
today astronomers call this
phenomenon Galactic
[Music]
cannibalism and so we bring our
understanding of the universe up to the
present day and our superficially calm
lives within the fully grown Milky Way
astronomers like Rodrigo have built
their observations on the shoulders of
giants previous generations of
astrophysicists and cosmologists working
together to model and test how galaxies
work and reaching back in time billions
of years to theorize how everything came
to be and yet if you were to believe the
headlines in
2022 all of this from Quantum ripples to
theories of Galaxy formation May have
been
fundamentally
[Music]
wrong this story opened with the mighty
Roar of a rocket on a Christmas morning
and a new view of the
universe shocked astronomers galaxies
that appeared to be far too large too
grown up blinking back at us from the
first billion years of the
cosmos one scientific paper even started
its title with panic at the disc discs
highlighting the shock that well-formed
dis galaxies appeared in the infant
Cosmos soon newspapers all around the
world were announcing that the James web
Space Telescope had brought an end to
cosmology itself was our entire
understanding of Galactic formation
under
threat around the globe cosmologists
nashed their teeth at the media
retention and leap to clarify what web
had seen what its observations really
meant and so so to understand this we
are going to have to delve into our
current model of the cosmos because it
all boils down to one key question what
kind of universe do we live
[Music]
in as many scientific stories do we
begin in the early Decades of the 20th
century Einstein had thrashed out his
general theory of relativity our modern
theory of gravity and with others such
as fredman and L Metra the the equations
that governed the cosmos were
derived these showed that the Universe
should be a dynamic Place expanding and
evolving as it aged in the 1920s
Hubble's observations showed this math
was an accurate description of reality
that galaxies were moving away from each
other due to the expansion of space and
as galaxies must have been closer
together in the past there must have
been a time where everything was
together a cosmic
creation our modern cosmology the Big
Bang had arrived the relativistic
cosmological equations however do not
predict a single specific Universe in
fact there are an infinite number of
possible universes mixed in the
mathematics so to single out our
universe astronomers needed to measure
two specific things about the universe
namely how fast is it expanding now and
just what does it
[Music]
contain the measured rate of of
expansion is known as the Hubble
constant and it tells you how quickly
galaxies are moving apart based on their
current separation the separation of
nearby galaxies is slower than those
further apart as there is more expansion
of space between the two distant objects
measuring the Hubble constant was a
major observational effort of the 20th
century with astronomers forming
factions around particular techniques
and measured values of the constant the
process was complicated as accurate
measurements of Galactic distances were
requ qu ired and as the universe doesn't
provide us with Cosmic rulers these were
notoriously difficult to measure for
half a century debate raged over whether
the Hubble constant was 50 or 100 when
expressed in cosmologists favorite unit
of kilomet per second per MEAP Parc but
by the 1990s the power of the Hubble
Space Telescope was brought to bear on
the problem and astronomers breathed a
sigh of relief when the measured value
was shown to be 72 about 235 km a second
per million light
years so with one of the key values
determined what about the content of the
universe this was an essential
ingredient as the presence of matter and
radiation drag on the expansion and
steadily slow down the cosmos with more
material providing more of a
deceleration as this influences the age
of the universe astronomers were Keen to
measure just how much stuff there was
counting Starlight was relatively easy
as you can simply PE through your
telescope and see the galaxies but
astronomers had come to realize there
was more to the universe than the Stars
you can see observations of the
rotations of galaxies and motions in
clusters of galaxies showed there was
much more the mass of the universe was
actually dominated by unseen dark matter
as dark matter is almost impossible to
observe astronomers decided on another
path they would chart the cosmic
expansion as they peered into the
distant universe and by mapping this
they could determine just how much dark
matter is pulling on
expansion by the 1990s two teams set out
using the light of exploding stars as
beacons to do just this the highed
Supernova search team and the Supernova
cosmology project the observational
challenges were substantial again
requiring accurate es to make the
measurements their focus was supern noi
1A Stars whose explosions appeared to be
essentially identical allowing them to
calibrate their true brightness and so
measure
distances and as the New Millennium
approached they had their chart of the
expansion history of the
universe but as they stared at the data
the astronomers were
confused they had expected due to the
presence of matter the cosmic expansion
should have steadily slowed but whilst
this had been the case in the early
universe in our time it was
not and so they were faced with the
question of what could be driving the
expansion faster and faster looking at
the relativistic equations of the cosmos
the culprit couldn't be matter or
radiation something else would have to
be added to the universe a new form of
energy throughout space and this energy
would have to have properties unlike
matter or radiation making it push
rather than pull on expansion this
mysterious substance not previously seen
in observations was dubbed Dark
[Music]
Energy but it was not only the presence
of dark energy that shocked astronomers
it was also the
amount they found that all matter
luminous and dark accounted for only 30%
of the cosmic energy budget with this
ubiquitous dark energy accounting for
the other 70 and as atoms in the form of
stars planets and gas make up about 5%
we truly live in a dark
Universe astronomers had isolated our
universe from the Myriad possibilities
the Infinity of options we finally knew
what Universe we lived
in they called this the Lambda CDM
cosmological model
Lambda signifying the presence of dark
energy while CDM stands for cold Dark
Matter the material that shapes the
formation and evolution of galaxies and
it was with this they could precisely
pinpoint the moment of creation a big
bang 13.8 billion years
ago with the Lambda CDM cosmological
model in hand we can calibrate the
universe light from distant objects is
red shifted due to the expansion of
space and we can tie this red shift to
the age of the universe when the light
began its Journey indeed it is this
cosmological model that tells us the
James web Space Telescope is seeing
galaxies in the first billion years of
the
cosmos and so do the observations of web
really threaten our cosmological
framework the difficulty is that the
mathematical equations of cosmology only
tell us about the large scale evolution
of the universe not what the detailed
flow of dark matter and gas into the
first galaxies to understand the growth
of galaxies we need to add more to the
cosmological
equations and it is here astronomers
face significant challenges as the
growth of galaxies depends on a wealth
of
factors these range from scales of
millions of light years charting the
flow of matter in the large scale
structure down to observing individual
galaxies and witnessing Starlight
throughout telescopes and we even need
to add the fragmentation of gas clouds
and the formation of stars into the mix
not only this but the first Stars evolve
fast and explode blasting material and
energy into the surroundings all this
needs to be tracked and traced in a
swirling environment where massive black
holes May lurk astronomers try to
capture all of this complexity into a
set of mathematical recipes and these
recipes represent our models of how
galaxies form and evolve but the key
here is in the plural as there is not a
single preferred model to explain it all
the physical conditions and processes of
the early Universe are in part
mysterious and unknown astronomers have
to resort to approximations and even
guesses in constructing aspects of their
models and it is the veracity of these
models that is being put to the test by
James
Webb
in the short time that has passed since
the claim of cosmology's demise the
excitement has died a little astronomers
have realized that there is enough slack
in their models to account for web's
observations a tune here and a tweak
there and the galaxies aspired by the
telescope are not that surprising
astronomers may have been LED astray by
some of the initial assumptions that
were
made take for example something that is
known as the Stellar initial Mass
function
this tells us the mix of stars formed
when a Giant gas cloud fragments and
collapses typically there will be a few
massive bright stars and lots of fainter
smaller stars but what if your Stellar
initial Mass function is wrong the
Stellar initial Mass function is
something we can measure and calculate
in the local universe but the assumption
that it was similar more than 10 billion
years ago is just that an
assumption we know that at the early
times the universe was very different
from today and so what if the Stellar
initial Mass function was also different
what if it was skewed and resulted in
the birth of more luminous stars than
expected then these baby galaxies would
burn more brightly than expected and
astronomers would estimate that they are
larger than
expected at the moment not everyone is
satisfied but the feeling is there is a
problem with models of Galaxy Evolution
the underlying cosmological model Lambda
CDM appears to be safe indeed if James
Webb is telling us anything it's that
the early Universe was more complicated
than we have so far
imagined and this is precisely what it
was designed to
do you've been watching the entire
history of the universe don't forget to
like And subscribe and leave us a
comment to tell us what you think thanks
for watching I will see you next
time